assalamualaikum brothers and sisters I
hope you're having a blast from my dad I
want to take a moment and comment on our
brother Andrew Tate who we haven't
forgotten about he's in our duas he said
my food comes at 8am noon and 5 PM I
have a plastic bag I use to try and
protect the food from insects I spend my
entire day destroying the Flies and the
Ants who get close to the meal
and now understand this so he gets his
food brought to him but he can't eat at
that time when the food is brought to
him so he's preserving his food
protecting his food from the flies into
insects and then Andrew goes on to say
in accordance with Ramadan when the Sun
goes down I eat the stone cold food in
my cell by myself and alhamdulillah
brother is fasting during this blessed
month of Ramadan it's one of the five
pillars of Islam he's done the first one
that first one is to testify that
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the creator of the heavens and the Earth
God Almighty Allah and that Muhammad is
the messenger of Allah and this would
include all the preceding Messengers and
just bring someone into Islam and then
I'm sure he's establishing the prayer
five times a day and he's connecting
he's doing slowly he's on his Road he's
on the road to success and I'm asking
you a question I'm going to ask you a
question in a minute we've seen him walk
into the Romanian court with this book
and many see now the wisdom we start to
see alhamdulillah because with all of
the distractions of this Dunya it's very
hard for many people especially someone
in his position with all the money and
all the glitz and glamor of this life to
sit down and to read the book so
alhamdulillah now our God almighty's
wisdom
he's put him in a position
that he can go ahead and connect with
his creator through the book that he
revealed the Quran and we see this this
is a phenomenon in places like this in
jails all across the U.S we've seen I've
interviewed people on this very topic
who work in the prison systems who have
testified that Islam is also in the
prison systems the fastest growing way
of life in the world why because when
people sit in these environments now
they start to contemplate and think
without all the distractions what's the
purpose of life why I've been created
and what they were born upon and all the
man-made religions that they were
exposed to don't make sense don't have
the evidence like the Quran does like
Islam does now how about ourselves our
brothers and sisters this is what I want
to leave you on if our brother Andrew
take can be out can be in that cell
pushing away fighting against the
insects to preserve his food so he can
eat he can be in that jail cell on the
road to success connecting with the
Quran what about you
what about you outside of that jail cell
in this Dunya are you making time for
your creator are you establishing that
direct Connection in Salat five times a
day are you fasting during this month of
Ramadan are you adhering to all of the
things that Allah had told us to do the
thing are you refraining from the things
that Allah has told us to refrain from
on your way through the spiritual boot
camp to get yourself closer to your
creator are you continuing that role you
still going to the nightclub you're
still fornicating
still gambling you still drinking
alcohol you're still selling alcohol so
this is just a quick reminder yes our
brother there
may Allah free him and become out
stronger in the dean and may Allah use
them for the Deen for the dawah when he
comes out of the jail inshallah
he's not been forgotten but this is a
great opportunity for us us to reflect
now as he's getting closer our brothers
getting close to the book are we getting
are you getting closer to the book are
you adhering to the book are you hearing
to the Quran and the Sunnah something to
think about assalamu alaikum Eddie is
taking this Amana very seriously he was
just sharing a story with me that they
had some benches inside that needed to
be moved and Eddie together Father and
Son were lifting these benches to join
us in this project inshallah so we can
establish a beautiful demons